hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to do a
topper war to your request from our
patreon page that comes from the hit
Bannerjee all righty
now for the video requests thought of
throwing something even more exciting
your way you've checked out cinematic
trailers for games but this time I'm
giving you a gameplay to check out
Rainbow six siege gameplay world
premiere this game came out a while ago
but keep it in tradition with his other
requests we're gonna check this out
anyway
John headphones Assemble
I see here we go what's the wrong Rod's
be careful
hmmm like real-life situations
that's a hell of a drug indetectable how
the hell can they not house truth
custody that drone wow these guys sound
like gamers actor should play the game
together before part of the team sound
like dudes online playing a game yeah so
I was supposed to be here I feel like
they're splitting the difference yeah
they wanted to sound like you're really
playing online but but not too much like
you're laughing online because they're
still talking about the game
[Music]
this poor woman's house
[Music]
eerily realistic enemies got the hostage
guys
yourself ma'am there are another grenade
in it do a barrel roll please destroy
this house
right on the ground versus me steps and
or stairs barricaded do well just grab
her
let's see drones exist there's gotta be
something really like this get in there
shoot him up oh damn
let's get out
you need to shoot the door just to make
sure
two versus one oh I like how this guys
Oh cliff-hanging me what did this did
the gamers win did the gamers who are
gaming together save the hostage today
did they just have to restart it how
many times that these gamers have to
play this specific mission yeah before
they can move on to the next mission
this was actually supposed to be a
gameplay tutorial where they win and
they just couldn't so finally they threw
up their hands and were like just submit
the one where you got the farthest and
that's what we got here every time I
watch anything like this or play any
game like this I'm always first taking
it back by should I be enjoying this
they're like real life situations that
happen I know real hostage situations
deaths home invasions people having to
go when people risking their lives and
dying and about two minutes in I'm
always like this is so look at them go I
can't wait to play this game look this
looks realistic this looks like a
actually anyway to have to get tactical
and go save a hostage from a house yeah
it's always that juxtaposition where the
first part is to other realism is don't
know and feel nauseous and the second
half is I love how realistic
[Laughter]
sensitization in yet yeah sensation but
ya know I mean this is badass and it
just reminded me of how not great I am
at first-person shooters so really it's
not your specialty no mostly cuz I
usually play with people who are really
good and you never get a chance to
practice really when you're in that
situation when you're with a group of
friends who are like yeah it's go online
you want to turn John Oh John sucks
though it's this one we're all gonna
kill you every time you respawn you're
dead again what's the story to this game
a splinter cell is the only tom clancy's
series of games I have touched with my
two hands I've always gotten the sense
that Rainbow six is you know like some
kind of tapped goal shooting an
extraction sort of game none of that is
present here yeah I mean yeah of course
this one took me aback in the setting I
mean I guess I usually associate what
I've seen of other Rainbow six games
with like more overtly war-torn areas
and stuff like that but I could
be wrong either way I was awesome yeah I
was pretty sweet that was very visceral
I was actually really hooked into the
gravity of the situation like when the
hostage got shot know what what happened
what and you know cuz there are so many
different shooters and it's easy to kind
of think of that video game stigma of
like oh you're just gonna lay on the
trigger and just spray bullets
everywhere but yeah even in the physics
of the game it seemed cool and
intriguing to be like okay it's not even
like you and a million other players
it's like you're a small unit see now
each one of you in this multiplayer
scenario is doing their own thing and
yeah it actually made me excited about
the idea for a moment of yeah getting
like three or four people together and
then you know like doing a little video
game mission you know ma you know how I
imagined like one fighter like MMA
fighters play like a UFC game and
they're playing it themselves that's how
I felt watching this yeah like oh this
is something I could easily do in real
life
you know I have the skills I go to LA
Fitness a few times a week it's really
all it takes you know it's kind of
overrated the training regimen I want to
say anything that I don't know how to do
I could probably figure out in like 30
minutes for me this was really exciting
cuz I was like oh yeah this is what I
could do in real life and now I'm seeing
it translated to a video game which just
makes me feel like I'm being honored
right now yeah when as an outsider it
was really cool to see what life looks
like through your eyes mm-hmm you know I
think I finally understand at least a
little bit the world of Griego people
ask what does Gregg do when he's not
filming or reactions extractions oh
that's what you meant no I was talking
about being one of the people who's
taking the girl hostage oh oh yeah copy
that yeah I don't know save her risk my
life stupid there's some good stuff
people will do things to get a person
back situations in real life are not
funny though hit thank you so much for
requesting this my dude it's gonna are
talking recently about how we both love
to draw inspiration from so many things
when it comes to creating our own work
he was telling me he draws from books
for ideas anime for character
development story arcs games for set
pieces films and show for dialogue it's
really cool to just know someone like
you likewise I learned how to
make love like sweet sweet passionate
love for um mean hentai Oh John I had to
said it first you you said it first
I learn from John yeah yes and I'll tell
you negotiating and I learned from him
yeah so you know by by the transitory
property you have learned from hentai
but I've perfected a lot of gnomes you
know there's a lot more you could learn
from things than the more than just
trying to enhance your storytelling I'm
talking life skills yeah pick up some
hentai today you can use our special
discount code real rejects anti reaches
2% on every purchase of hentai today
just for you exclusively Mohit guys you
can subscribe or the reject nation click
that notification bell and we'll check
you guys house now